aber ich hab so zugenommen hey leute was
jetzt gekommen war ein video der
wirtschaft natürlich ganz gut es sind ja
noch drei tage bis weihnachten und ich
habe mir gedacht bei euch heute mal im
hintergrund eine schöne weihnachtliche
atmosphäre auf nein spaß das war nicht
auf jeden fall auf jeden fall habe ich
mich für heute mal wieder etwas ganz
besonderes überlegt mit dabei ist heute
die besonders wir was habe ich noch mal
letzte mal gesagt ach ja immer wie ist
auch dabei jetzt haben sie eigentlich
auch wieder rausgehen aus dem bild und
zwar es mir wirklich einen gedankenblitz
gekommen alex dazu musste ein video
machen da brauchst du zwar auch mädchen
führen da bist du mir eingefallen und
zwar hat sich die maria jetzt zehn
aussagen überlegt die mädchen halt sagen
beziehungsweise frauen ab wann ist man
eigentlich eine frau liliana ab 18
ja ja ja und vor allem erziehung zum
beispiel man weiß ja eigentlich mädchen
sagen nicht immer die wahrheit also sie
sagen das war aber mein ein komplett
anderes und in diesem videos einfach das
ziel gleich sechs mal hier und wird eine
aussage sagen und ich sag dann was
mädchen mit dieser aussage eigentlich
wirklich meinen also mal ein ganz dummes
beispiel also mal ein ganz tolles
beispiel ich habe keins ihr wisst
bestimmt was ich meine falls nicht
sollte er es jetzt im video verstehen
lässt schon mal daumen nach oben dafür
noch ein paar wenn ihr das feiert und
natürlich sagen na ja also ich mache mir
jetzt nicht so wirklich was aus den
beiden dienstag also ich bin generell
irgendwie so gar nicht der romantische
typ frau ja deshalb also das heißt dann
dass also das ist eigentlich dann so
weil eigentlich sind ja ganz normal
weiter ich habe wirklich noch münchen
zeigt noch nie jemand etwas geschenkt
so kann auf jeden fall sind ja alle
mädchen oder frauen so irgendwie so voll
auf valentinstag also die finden das so
voll geil und männer eigentlich galt das
ist eigentlich nur so ein tag wo man ein
bisschen irgendwie geld ausgeben muss
für irgendeinen dummes geschenkt was im
endeffekt eh kein jung aber dann gibt es
halt frauen die gegen den strom
schwimmen möchte und sagen valentinstag
das finde ich blöd obwohl sie eigentlich
dann das gar nicht so meint sondern ist
auch cool finden ich hätte das ist nicht
ganz so ich hatte jetzt gesagt ich sagt
eine frau ich bin weiter takt für takt
und ich bin nicht so der romantisch die
frau am main genau das gegenteil also
nicht um gegen den strom zu schwimmen
sondern weil ich genau das gegenteil ich
möchte dass man mir a
genau das wollte ich sagen ja das war
ein bisschen beruf von mir überlegt dann
macht es nicht so also ich bin überhaupt
nicht eifersüchtig wirklich nicht jetzt
sagen wir dann weil das eigentlich jeder
junge hören möchte weil das eigentlich
mega cool ist wenn jemand nicht
eifersüchtig ist aber im endeffekt das
ding ist wenn jemand sagt ich bin nicht
eifersüchtig das geht gar nicht weil ich
glaube das liegt so in der mine ja aber
wenn man jetzt die andere person sehr
markt sag ich mal dass man auch einfach
süchtig das ist einfach eine menschen
drin
ich weiß nicht vielleicht ist es bei
tieren auch so keine ahnung wenn der
eine hase plötzlich mit dem anderen
hasen was hat vielleicht der dritte hase
auch als in der natur ein
geschwisterchen bekommen sind die
automatisch eifersüchtig richtig erweist
so war es der neue freund meiner besten
freundin der ist so mega siehst zu er
falsch also für die ist immer noch nicht
verstanden haben es geht ja darum was
mädchen sagen und was sie wirklich
meinen steht auf dem titel und das heißt
ganz klar dass man auch ein freund haben
möchte man möchte dass er noch süßes
isst ja stimmt wieder das mädchen jungs
sagen
also jetzt weil es ja mein geburtstag
aber draußen wirklich nichts zu schenken
also wirklich das heißt dass man nur
dann daran erinnern möchte dass man
wirklich erst mal geburtstag hat dass er
das nicht vergisst und zweitens
natürlich möchte man was zum geburtstag
haben das ist ja ein schon wieder das
gegenteil das war ja einfach jedoch auch
mainz fitness studio sport ist so gesund
dass ich fett bin
hallo ich interpretiere mal ein bisschen
mehr das ist unsportlich bin dass ich
bin ja soo wahrheit das trainiert sein
kann so etwas auf das heißt an sich dass
ich mehr muskeln haben sollte mein
bizeps explodiert manchmal also ich bin
nicht so eine also die die schon das
sagen so ich bin nicht so eine sind halt
erst richtig die so eine sind man muss
ja dann auch definieren was für eine
also ich finde am witzigsten sind die
iren irgendwie über ihre freundin so was
schlechtes sagen und sein so h die hatte
was mit ihm und mit dem und dem ich bin
aber nicht so einen obwohl es hier
genauso eine sind ja genau das gemeint
ab so leute alex wird schließlich in der
beschreibung das passt ja selbst dass du
das sagst du mir bitte du kriegst auch
auf jeden fall morgen wieder schickte
mich wieder
ich habe keinen hunger manches davon ist
aber auch echt ein schock
ich habe keinen hunger heißt eigentlich
direkt dass man es unangenehm findet sag
ich mal eine person die man jetzt nicht
so gut kennt oder ein junge den man
vielleicht gerade erst einmal kennen
lernt dass man halt nicht möchte dass
dieser junge einen beim essen beobachtet
wie man ist oder wie viel man isst oder
sonst was
ich bin so gut ich hab so zugenommen
das ist auch ganz einfach und heißt
eigentlich nur dass man hören möchte das
war nicht zugenommen hat und immer noch
die perfekte figur hat also ich muss
schon sagen ich hab echt im dunkel
kummer wie dunkles draußen ich habe echt
angst alleine ist noch mit der bahn
hause zu fahren ja das ist auch ganz
einfach das heißt eigentlich nur dass
man dann vielleicht noch bei der person
bleiben möchte wo man gerade ist
oder dass diese personen nach hause
fährst oder so ja leute das waren 10
aussagen ihr könnt ihr mal weiter in die
kommentare schreiben
mal sehen sonst macht alexandra sieben
oder neun unserer neuen tickets elemente
gefallen hat lassen dann nach oben da
schaut man bei marie und ministerium
verweist sie kurz eingeblendet und
morgen gibt's natürlich neues video wir
sehen uns morgen ich wünsche euch einen
schönen tag haut rein